[Music]
hey you guys
me again time for the tomes of tarot
show where i review
horror books old and new and today we're
going to be talking about
this book right here sharp objects
by gillian flynn so let's do this so
i had been hearing a lot about gillian
flynn probably she's most uh famous for
her book gone girl which was made into
uh you know a movie that was very
successful um
and i had seen like a lot of her books
um you know recommended
by various other horror channels so i
decided this would be a good place to
start because uh
sharp objects is actually her first
novel it came out in 2006
now what i didn't know when i read the
book was that i guess they've done
like an eight-episode mini-series of it
on hbo
which i have not seen amy adams is in it
and um
sophia lillis who was in uh the it's
chapter one
um so i would kind of be interested to
see that i sort of like read a synopsis
real quick and it sounds like it's
you know hemming pretty close to the
book and i've heard good things about it
like uh you know the reviews and stuff
are good
but you know i just i wanted to read the
book first now i will say
this book i read it in
one day i mean it's not super long it's
probably like 250 260 pages something
like that
but even though it's not long a lot of
[ __ ] happens in it and there's like a
really lot
of you know character depth and you know
there's just so much stuff going on and
they're like so much
and i will say too that this book is
[ __ ] up there's like some [ __ ] up
stuff going on in this
now i guess that
it's sort of classified as a thriller
mystery
type thing because it's like a serial
killer and you know they're trying to
figure out who it is
i will say that i don't think i honestly
i think that
it's less like a thriller like a
whodunit
type of thing as i feel like you can
kind of figure out who did it or you
know kind of at least
get in the ballpark of what's going on i
think
what it's really excels at more than
that i don't even think that's like the
main thrust of the book
i think like the main thrust of the book
is the character study
of the main character his name is
camille and
her coming to terms with the murders
coming to terms with her past
um you know and and everything that that
entails like all of the trauma and [ __ ]
that she experiencing then so i think
it's more like a character study than a
mystery
um it does have horror elements but it's
not like supernatural or anything like
that
so here's the synopsis there's this
woman named
camille preaker uh it's told from her
point of view it's in the
the whole book is in the first person um
she
like grew up in this little bitty town
called wind gap missouri i don't know if
it's a real town or not
um and they're kind of known for like
hog farming
and she had a really wealthy family like
her uh mom
adora owned like a lot of the hog farms
in there so like most of the people in
the town like worked for her so she had
grown up in this mansion
now she had a terrible childhood in the
fact that adora
is kind of a horrible person
like a horrible mother she's very cold
she's very distant she's very
weird and so that like messed her up so
she um eventually she started
self-harming
um she later became an alcoholic which
she still kind of is in the book
when the when the book takes place like
in the present and uh
she eventually ended up moving away now
she did a stint in
a mental hospital for all of the cutting
that she was doing
and a specific type of cutting where
she's always like cutting
words into her flesh um so it's kind of
like all over her body
like all these scars that she has so she
had done this stint she moved to the big
city she moved to chicago
and ended up working for a newspaper in
chicago that was like
third tier so at the beginning of the
story
her editor who was also kind of like her
father figure cause she didn't really
have one when she was growing up
and he has been since he's like the
editor of this
sort of paper in chicago that's like
that nobody reads it's kind of like the
third or fourth one down like in the
[ __ ]
hierarchy or whatever so he's always
trying to like get that big story that's
gonna like break them like nationally
so he's saying hey there was this one
guy at this little texas paper and he
wrote he went back to his hometown to
like write about these murders
and um that one a pulitzer and maybe
that [ __ ] should happen too
so it so happened that in the little
town where camille grew up
uh win gap missouri there's been like
really weird
murders there was one murder of like a
nine or ten year old girl
who was killed and then her teeth were
all removed that happened like the
previous year
and then when the story starts another
little girl has disappeared so they're
kind of
like starting to suspect that maybe
there's some serial killer action going
on
and because camille grew up in this town
and because
the town is so small that you know the
larger newspapers haven't really caught
wind of the story yet
so the editor named curry like
sends her back to the hometown to
investigate the murders and
write like a big feature story about it
because he's hoping that it will
you know sell papers or whatever so she
ends up
going back to this hometown and
kind of she ends up having to stay with
her mother because she works for a very
small like newspaper and they can't
afford to like put her up in a hotel or
anything so she ends up having to stay
with her mom
and her stepdad and also her half
sister now she also had a sister that
died named marion
when uh marion was a little girl and
this girl her half sister who she i
don't believe she's ever met before this
time because i don't think she's been
back to the town for like eight years or
something like that because she's
estranged from her family
so she comes back and this little girl
emma is 13
and the way that the mom
like dotes on this little girl and this
little girl
is like super messed up too and she's
like
she acts like real childlike or princess
like
when she's in the presence of her mom
and dad but then when she's like out on
her own
she's like a total hellion she's like
super cruel she's like
druggy she's like super promiscuous
she's like she's just messed up
so there's all of that [ __ ] going on too
so i will say if you are bothered
by reading about you know people who cut
if you are bothered by 13 year old girls
getting up to some
really questionable shenanigans
then probably this will not be for you
because this book
goes to some pretty dark areas like as
far as family dynamics and stuff like
that go
and so like i said because it's kind of
i guess it was kind of sold as a
thriller and i guess it kind of is
in the sense that it's a serial killer
type story or it's a murder mystery type
story
but i think the mystery uh you know the
whodunit aspect is
you know secondary i think it's like
less important
because i didn't guess exactly what was
going on but i
kind of got you know i kind of got in
the ballpark of what was going on
but i but it that didn't bother me i
think that
where this book really shines is the
examination of camille's character this
broken
you know traumatized character who's
just trying to other than like this
horrible like upbringing that she had
and she's kind of trying to make a life
away from that but then she kind of gets
thrust back into it and then there's
like these two little girls
and like this really insular town where
everybody knows everything about
everybody and everybody's gossiping
about everybody and everybody's
suspecting everybody of the murders
and so there's like this horrible like
oppressive like small town kind of [ __ ]
going on too
and then she has all the [ __ ] that she's
going through with her horrible
mother and her horrible half-sister
who's just like yikes um that kind of
character
so it's just like a really good
examination
of this just really messed up
like family dynamic i mean seriously i
was reading it and like i said i read
this all in like one day it was like
sunday
and as soon as i you know had finished
my [ __ ] for the day i was just kind of
like okay i'll start reading this and i
just started reading and it started
reading and starting and i couldn't like
put it down
i wasn't going to read the whole thing
in one day but i just ended up reading
it in in one day so
no no shame you know another thing too
like the main character i've
seen like some other people's this seems
like it got like really
like positive reviews i mean especially
for a debut novel this is
one of the best like first novels that
i've ever read very very accomplished
i mean gillian flynn i guess she had
written for entertainment weekly prior
to that so it's not like she was just
coming out of nowhere but
this was actually her first novel and
it's like really good like the character
work is good
i will say that it took a couple of
pages for me to kind of
get into the head of the character and
like the way that she
because like i said it's in the first
person like the way that she
communicated
like her stuff to the audience now some
reviews
and i i went into this a little bit on
my review of uh
if you see her by and by anya albarn as
well
i saw that some people thought that the
main character of camille
um whose eyes were seeing the whole
story through was unlikable
which again i can see that um she came
across to me
very much like jessica jones like a
jessica jones type character
who had like all of this messed up like
a horribly messed up
childhood you know a mother who
apparently didn't like
didn't love her and like says that
outright and like the way that she
treats her is just like
[ __ ] horrifying and it's just like i
was reading some of the scenes going oh
my god it's like i couldn't
it's you know because it made me feel
like it was like well i had a relatively
normal
childhood and a normal like relationship
with my mom and stuff and this was just
like
i couldn't imagine so so she struck me
very much like that as this kind of
you know she had been through all this
[ __ ] when she was younger no nobody
loved her she had you know gone through
all the self-harm and everything
turned everything back in on herself but
she still like had this really hard
shell that she was projecting to the
outside world like to
you know to deal with it and to make her
way in life
but really she's just like super
vulnerable it's literally you know she's
just like she's always
drinking it's like she's always making
really
bad decisions you know what i mean like
in terms of like sleeping with people
shouldn't sleep with
um doing drugs with people she shouldn't
do drugs with you know things like that
so she's always making like
bad decisions but i did not find that
that made her unlikable and
in a lot of ways i kind of i i think
that's one of the best things about the
book is that
you can see how she might come across as
unlikable because you're just like oh my
god why are you doing this like stupid
thing
but you can always you can also
understand
like especially when she gets to wind
gap in the book and
starts interacting with her mother and
you know i was thinking myself holy
oh my god like if that was what my
relationship with my mother was like
i can totally see how you might have
gone on the same road
another thing that i thought was really
interesting too and i don't think this
is giving too much away like i said some
of these book discussions are more like
i don't really i you know i want people
to read the books but
in a lot of ways i like to do like more
of discussion thing
rather than because then i don't have to
worry too much about like giving
out spoilers like mild spoilers like i
said i'm not going to tell anybody how
it ended i'm not going to tell anybody
who the murderer was or anything like
that but you know some aspects of the
book if you don't want to know anything
about the book
you probably should read the book before
you watch the review because i might
give some [ __ ] away that you
might not wanted to know like before you
write it so
just fyi another thing that i thought
was really interesting too was that
i guess the ways that a mother could
affect
her daughters like in different ways
because you have one that kind of like
turned things inward you have another
daughter that kind of turned things
outward even though they had gotten
not they didn't really get treated the
same because that's kind of one of the
things that's going on in the book
you know just an interesting thing like
have these this horrible dysfunctional
family like how
it affects different types of people
different personality types like growing
up in that household
so i found that really interesting as
well if i had
one criticism and it's a very minor
criticism
the end was kind of abrupt because i
think it felt like i kind of called it
and i guess like i said i've seen some
other i haven't read either of her other
books she has gone girl and i think she
has one called dark places
and i'm definitely going to read both of
those and i you know will probably
review them at some point in the future
but i've heard that that's kind of her
thing that she'll do like a twist
ending sort of and then like at the very
end it'll be like another twist you're
like oh [ __ ]
so this is definitely kind of like that
i don't know if it was a twisty twist
like you know what i mean because i kind
of sort of knew where it was gonna go
not exactly but it seemed like
it ended and then there was an epilogue
and then like a whole bunch of stuff
like happened just like in the epilogue
like in the last couple pages
like it jumped ahead a lot and was like
oh by the way this this this this
happened
like i said i didn't mind it because it
was kind of like a you know like a punch
in the gut like a big impact
but also it kind of left you wanting
more like well
can you like expand on that a little bit
can we unpack that a little bit more
but like i said that's a very minor
criticism
and i'm still not sure like if i
liked it better the way it was because
it just like left things like pow and
then like left
you know rather than just going on and
on and you'd be like yeah yeah we get
the point or whatever
so i don't know i don't know how i feel
about it but like i said um
this was a really messed up but like a
lot of really messed up stuff happens in
this
like i said it's very short but it
kind of goes a lot of [ __ ] happens in it
and a lot of
uh you know dark character traits and a
lot of really [ __ ] up [ __ ] is explored
so you know if that sounds like
something you would like if you liked
gone girl if you saw the movie or
whatever
like i said i think they did make uh
sharp objects
into a series or a mini series rather i
think it's eight episodes
on hbo with amy adams who also produced
it i believe
um i have not seen it although i've
heard that it's very good
so i might want to watch it at some
point because yeah i i wouldn't mind
seeing an adaptation of this because
this was like pretty messed up
so like i said this is more on the
thriller end of things than
straight up horror because it's not
supernatural but it's super dark
it's super messed up like seriously
[ __ ] up really [ __ ] up [ __ ] happens
in this so
if that's gonna bother you don't read it
but other than that
i really liked it i mean like i said i
don't want to start giving
star ratings for everything but probably
four out of five on this one
um it was really really compelling once
i got
into the narration style like the
character
camille's character and the way that she
talked and the way she thought and the
way she related it took me like two or
three pages to kind of get
catch the wave of that but once i did i
really i couldn't put it down like i
just like sat there and just like
i just sat here at my desk like with my
neck all cr all creaking and i just like
read
through the whole [ __ ] thing so it
was a really compelling
read i find i found it very compelling
if you like that kind of thing then
definitely by all means check it out and
i'll see you on the next one bye